hey guys it's justine and today we are
checking out the 13 and a half inch hp
elite folio two in one laptop inside
this box
is a super versatile device that is
basically made for on-the-go
productivity it weighs just under three
pounds but it will still give you all
the processing power you need with the
snapdragon 8cx
gen2 compute platform let's unbox a huge
thank you to hp for sponsoring this
video i'm so excited to check this out
there's nothing i love more than
checking out new devices
especially two and ones cause i do plan
on traveling
you know a little more than we did in
the past year which these types of
devices are perfect for that and i am
actually heading to the airport
right after i unbox this to go visit my
family i've been traveling back and
forth visiting them as much as i can
so super excited to take this with me
on a flight this is going to be a real
life
test of on-the-go productivity
oh
oh what is this
here it is whoa i actually thought this
was just a case
this is the whole dev what
oh yes i love these hp braided
charging cables i reviewed a bunch of hp
laptops
in my youtube career so it's always very
exciting
to see the varying accessories that they
have in them and this is honestly like
one of my favorite chargers and it's
nice because it's not just an all-black
color like it's a nice little gray so
it's a really nice contrast
what's this oh
oh this looks like it's a little
accessory for the hp
pen very nice box presentation i love
that they show you
the different ways that you can use the
device
instructions i still can't believe that
this is this is the this is it
how long has this water bottle been
sitting there justine
it's almost like you've never made a
youtube video before
oh my gosh it has like what the heck
this is so freaking cool like this is
it's like a leather type finish at the
top
and the bottom premium experience
this is cool okay so that kind of makes
sense why they're calling it like a
folio because it
kind of feels like a little portfolio
that you would be like carrying
this is this is really cool like this
i feel like a business executive a
seat i just ripped my hair out i can't
even make that up i was gonna say i'm a
ceo i don't even
think that i deserve the title but i am
one
which is crazy to think i'm gonna be
hodling the crypto
doing my stock exchanges
transferring my crypto from various
wallets
this is so nice like i'm honestly so
in shock like wow this is so nice like
look at this
i wasn't even i was not ready for that
look how freaking thin this is
this allows you to like switch this so
easily
into tablet mode did you see what i just
did there
and the thing that i like about that is
sometimes there's different two and ones
that
actually flip over to the keyboard on
this side
but because it's like this really
nice like leathery material it'll like
sit nicely on your lap it won't slide
you won't be hitting keys
ah so cool this also has built-in
cellular so if you are on the go you
won't have to be hunting for a wi-fi
network which is something that i was
always struggling with when i was
working at different coffee shops
but if you do need wi-fi this does
utilize wi-fi six
you really can seamlessly transform this
from laptop mode
to tablet mode name something more
seamless
i don't think you can so this display is
13.5 inches with a
3x2 aspect ratio it has 16 gigs of ram
it's eight cores have a stock speed
up to 3.15 gigahertz i always love when
devices like this that have built-in
cameras have privacy in mind when it
comes to these integrated cameras
it is kind of crazy to think that we
have these things in our lives that have
built-in cameras
well this is cool because this has a
little integrative switch that you could
turn
on or off so that allows your camera to
be visible
or not visible this is actually a really
well designed switch because it's so
small and subtle this is the
rechargeable hp elite slim active pen
which is great for taking notes editing
photos or just
doodling it's cool because it does
quickly charge right here in the
built-in storage space
right above the keyboard i haven't even
turned this thing on and i'm already
super impressed with the design let's
plug this in and get you all charged and
set up
and take you on the road
[Music]
oh so i magically have transported to a
new location
i'm on the east coast i plan on making a
really cool montage and vlogging on the
flight and
how i use this the only thing that i did
on that overnight red-eye flight
was uh close my eyes and sleep traveling
again was kind of interesting because if
i had been wide awake and on this crazy
long flight to get back to the east
coast from the west coast this would
have been such a great device
because honestly it really is so light
it is so compact
and the one thing after using this for
the past week
i love this cover so much it's so
different not having like a metallic
cover on here and it just being sort of
this little folio like i talked about
it's like my little portfolio but i've
been using this so much around the house
my sister
she has a little girl her name is brynn
and she
well she's very very smart which is
great but
it could be problematic because she
figures out everything so she also
figured out that when i hold this
up it unlocks so she will pick it up and
try to hold it in front of my face
because i have the face unlock on
so it's so cute seeing her use this and
use the hp
pen
[Music]
[Applause]
that's not the right end though look
this way
[Music]
if you use your finger too look
gotta use this end
[Music]
isn't that fun what do you have there
can i see it hold it up
show her let me see oh you want to keep
it
you didn't want to share and show you
what else we can do we check this out
we can go like this this flips down like
that
it's now a laptop so you can type we
have to be gentle
type soft so
yes type soft two hints two for typing
this is an hp folio what do you think of
it do you like it
yes
we've been watching content i also
taught her how to draw i will say that
over the course of the week like her
drawings have
improved slightly i mean i think i might
still be a better artist but i guess i
kind of do have an age advantage
the other thing that i love is it is so
light but yet it is so powerful so
not only am i able to do just basic
things like do email
but i have actually been gaming on this
and that's been really fun as well
i know i showed you guys in the unboxing
how easy it is to switch from tablet
mode to laptop mode but as i've been
using it
more throughout this past week it has
this really unique pool forward design
that lets you use various modes like
tablet
media consumption or a clamshell mode
for productivity the hp speakers with
audio tuned by bang
olufsen also sound really great and i
love that it's a touch screen
sometimes i forget when i'm using other
devices that are laptop
like and they don't have a touch screen
and i touch the screen and it doesn't
work
and i get upset it's also funny tying
back to bryn using these devices because
she has basically grown up in a
touch-based
environment so anytime she touches a
computer or a tv and it doesn't actually
respond
she's kind of confused so it's been kind
of cool to see her realize that not only
is this a laptop but she can also touch
the screen
this has been such a great device to
consume content on
obviously i am a content creator so i
have been watching a lot of my content
back before i post it to make it live
i've also been editing some of my social
content on here i've been doing photo
editing for a bunch of my posts
and it's been working really well for
everything that i've needed the battery
life has also been incredible and being
able to stay connected with wi-fi lte 4g
and even 5g while traveling has helped
out so much this can also be hooked up
to dual 4k
external monitors so when i head back
home i can have a full workstation
i like having this leather outer folio
case on it because it actually
stays on my lap when i'm sitting and
doing work and if i'm on the couch it
doesn't slide off so not only does it
look really nice
it actually serves a really great
purpose it does have the bang olufsen
speakers so you actually are getting a
really good quality sound as well
it's great for watching children shows
or listening to
my own music or movies this also has lte
and the one thing that my parents have
at their house
is um terrible internet thankfully there
is some cell reception there so the lte
on this is actually way better than
their internet connection
so i've been using the lte over the
wi-fi well thank you guys so much for
watching this is a really fun look at
the hp elite folio this thing is
honestly so awesome and i look forward
to
using it so much more in my daily
workflow if you guys are new here be
sure to subscribe and hit the bell so
you'll be learned when i post new videos
and i look forward to seeing you guys in
my next video
bye